now that we have distance explicitly as
a function of the angle that we're
shooting the object at we can use a
little bit of calculus to figure out the
optimal angle the angle that's going to
optimize our distance and since we only
care but about angles that from 0
degrees to really 90 degrees let's
constrain ourselves so we're going to
optimize things for angles between 0
degrees so theta is going to be greater
than or equal to 0 and less than or
equal to
90. so let's see how we can do it and
just to get an idea of what we're even
conceptually doing with the calculus
remember when you take a derivative you
are finding the slope of a line and into
an instantaneous slope of a line and if
you were to graph this and i encourage
you to graph it on your own maybe with a
graphing calculator it will look like it
looks something like this over the
interval
it will look like this
where that is the distance as a function
of theta axis
and then this would be
our theta axis and we care about angles
between 0 and 90 degrees so if you were
to graph this thing
so this is 0 degrees this is maybe 90
degrees right here the graph of this
function will look like
will look like this it'll look something
like this
it will look something like that and
what we want to do is find the angle
there's some angle here there's some
angle here that gives us the optimal
distance so this is right here this is
the optimal
optimal
the optimal distance and what we want to
do is find that out and when you look at
the graph and you could do it on on a
graphing calculator if you like
what happens to the instantaneous slope
at that optimal distance
what's flat the slope there is zero
the slope there is zero
so we need to do is take the derivative
of this function and then just figure
out at what angle is the derivative or
the instantaneous slope of this function
equal to zero and then we're done we
will know this mystery angle this
optimal angle to shoot the object at so
let's take the derivative
so the derivative we'll just use our
derivative rules here
the derivative
of i would call it d prime i guess or we
could say the derivative of the distance
with respect to theta is equal to we're
assuming that s and g are constants so
we don't have to worry about them right
now we could just put them out front
since we're assuming they're constants
and then we could do the product rule to
take the derivative of this part with
respect to theta and the product rule
in the product rule we take the
derivative of the first function times
the second function so the derivative of
cosine of theta is negative sine of
theta
negative sine of theta and we're going
to multiply that times the second
function
so that's times sine of theta
and to that we're going to add we're
going to add the first function which is
cosine of theta
times the derivative of the second
function the derivative of sine theta is
cosine of theta
is cosine of theta i know it's a little
bit confusing all we did is we took the
derivative of the first one times the
second one and then we took the
derivative of the second one times the
first one
let me make it even more explicitly
clear we took the derivative of this guy
here so this is the derivative with
respect to theta and we took the
derivative of this guy over here with
respect to theta
we took the derivative of cosine there
multiply it by sine took the derivative
of sine here multiply it by cosine just
the product rule now what does this give
us we can simplify this a good bit so we
could write
the derivative
d prime is equal to we could keep this
constant out there 2s squared over g
times now negative sine of theta times
sine of theta that's just negative sine
squared of theta and then cosine theta
times cosine theta that's just plus
cosine squared of theta now what we just
said is we want to figure out the point
the the angle at which this derivative
or the instantaneous slope is zero so
let's set this thing equal to
zero so we just have to solve for theta
now now the first thing i do to solve
for theta the first thing i would do to
solve for theta is just divide both
sides by 2s squared over g if you divide
the left hand side by that it cancels
out with 2s squared over g and if you
divide 0 by that assuming that this
isn't 0 which it shouldn't be then
you'll still get 0. so this equation
simplifies to i'll write it in blue
negative sine squared of theta plus
cosine squared of theta is equal to zero
now if we add sine squared of theta to
both sides of this equation
let's add sine squared of theta to both
sides
we are left with
these cancel out cosine squared of theta
is equal to sine squared of theta
sine squared of theta now both of these
are going to be positive over the
interval so we're going to take the
positive square root of both of them or
the principal root of both sides of this
equation
so let's do that so you take the
principal roots of both sides of this
equation
you could do it that way actually a more
interesting way than doing it that way
is to divide both sides of this equation
by cosine squared of theta
assuming that it's not equal to zero
over this interval so cosine squared of
theta
cosine squared of theta you could also
do it using the positive square root the
principal root either one will work but
this is interesting because the left
hand side cancels out to 1 and 1 will be
equal to what's sine squared over cosine
squared of theta well that's the same
thing as
sine of theta
over
cosine of theta
cosine over cosine of theta
squared
right you have the square divided by
another square that's the same thing as
the fir as the numerator divided by the
denominator that whole thing squared and
what's sine of theta divided by cosine
of theta
well that's just the tangent of theta
that's just the tangent of theta
so we have 1 is equal to
is equal to the tangent squared of theta
or we could take the positive square
root of both sides of this equation
tangent is positive over the interval
from 0 to 90 degrees so that's cool to
do so if you take the positive square
root of both sides you get the positive
square root of 1 is 1.
1 is equal to tangent of theta tangent
of theta and then you take the inverse
tan of both sides or the arctan of both
sides and you get
you get
the arctan of 1
arc tan
of 1 is equal to theta and this is just
a very fancy way of saying theta is the
angle that if you were to take its
tangent you get one and you could use a
calculator to solve that or you might
not you might just know that by memory
this theta the arc tangent of 1 is 45
degrees
is
45 degrees or if you are dealing in
radians it is pi
over
radians either one of those is going to
work so our optimal angle when we shoot
this thing is going to be at 45
degrees now what is that optimal
distance going to be when we shoot it
off at 45 degrees well we can just go
back to our original formula
we just go back to our original formula
that we derived if we're shooting it off
at 45 degrees what is the sine of 45
degrees the sine
of 45 degrees is equal to the square
root of 2 over 2. you could use a
calculator for that or maybe you know it
from the unit circle the cosine
of 45 degrees is also square root of 2
over 2. and if you'd actually just taken
the principal roots at this stage of the
equation you'd have gotten it some that
the cosine of theta has to equal sine of
theta over this interval and that only
happens at 45 degrees but given this we
can put this back into the original into
the original
expression
right up here
our original function so the optimal
distance that we are going to travel
so distance
as a function the distance we travel at
45 degrees is going to be equal to
is equal to 2 s squared over g
times cosine of theta which is square
root of 2 over 2
cosine of 45 square root of 2 over 2
times sine of theta which is square root
of 2 over 2.
well what's the square root of 2 times
the square root of 2
well that's just 2.
let me simplify this so the square root
of 2 times the square root of 2 that is
2.
this 2 cancels out with that 2 and then
this 2 cancels out with this 2 so then
the optimal distance you travel at 45
degrees all we're left with is the s
squared
s squared over g assuming no air
resistance kind of an ideal circumstance
but no matter what planet you're on
what's how fast you do it the best angle
is always 45 degrees assuming no air
resistance and if you do it on that best
angle you're going to travel s squared
over g so if s
going back to the original problem if s
is 10 meters per second let's say s was
10 meters per second
is 10 meters per second and let's say
we're dealing with a world where let's
say gravity is equal to
10 meters per second squared then
according to what we've derived your
optimal distance
the optimal distance
optimal
distance
is going to be
s squared so it's going to be a hundred
it's going to be 100 divided by gravity
it's going to be 10. and if you square
meters per second you're going to get
meters squared per second squared
divided by the acceleration of gravity
meters per second squared second squares
cancel out you have a meter squared
divided by meters you're left with your
optimal distance would be 10 meters
pretty neat